Speaker 1: A former New Jersey Republican
governor, Chris Christie, is the author of
a new book.
It's one of these kind of trash political
books, and he was interviewed.
He did the media rounds.
Yesterday, he was interviewed on CNN.
He was interviewed a bunch of different places.
But the most interesting interview that Chris
Christie did was with Nicolle Wallace on MSNBC.
I'm not some big Nicolle Wallace fan.
I think she often does interesting interviews,
and she really made Chris Christie look as
stupid as the book appears to be on the subject
matter.
So let let me kind of give you the backstory.
Chris Christie, former Republican governor
of New Jersey involved in that horrifying
Bridgegate scandal where they shut down a
lane of the George Washington Bridge as a
political punishment to the mayor of I don't
remember what Jersey Town for something over
a political disagreement.
Just a disgusting, disgusting thing.
Christie ran for the Republican nomination
in 2016.
Slam Donald Trump really, really hard.
And then eventually fell in line and was famously
pictured standing behind Trump, looking ill
like he had some bad clams as he was now endorsing
Trump and Trump behaving as Trump always does
in completely embarrassing fashion.
And Chris Christie looking ill.
And then he has tried to kind of frame himself
as, OK, I did support Trump.
But then I also have concerns about trying
to play every side of the Republican Party.
So now Chris Christie writes this book, he's
going to tell the Republican Party how to
save itself.
The book is called Republican Rescue, Saving
the Party from truth deniers conspiracy theorists.
And the dangerous policies of Joe Biden, well,
the Republican Party needs to be rescued from
Trump, it's really not about Joe Biden at
all, and I apologize.
I just punched my microphone there.
So it's just one of these garbage books enough
with all the infighting, the truth denying
the wild conspiracy claims, the looking backward,
the refusal to focus on the dangerous Biden
agenda.
Here's Chris Christie's urgent guide for recapturing
Republican glory what and winning elections
again told with the New Jersey frankness and
news breaking insights that made the two term,
two term Governor Trump early endorser and
presidential candidate an indispensable voice.
It's just completely bonkers, and one of the
things about the book and you can look at
the um, I wanted to pull up the table of contents
for you guys, but I'm unable to right now.
One of the things about the book is it sort
of seems to miss no one like the main source
of right wing conspiracies, which is right
wing media, including Fox News and these other
networks.
He talks about CNN, and he talks about, you
know, all these other news networks doesn't
talk about Fox News and good for her.
Nicolle Wallace calls him out, and it's painful
in the best of ways to see how just silly
Chris Christie looks.
Take a look at this.
You know,
Speaker 2: the book is called It's about conspiracies
and lies, and you really don't take on Fox
News.
Why not?
Speaker 3: Look, because the Politicker can't
go.
Because, because the book?
No, I don't watch it.
Speaker 2: But the book is aware of what he
does.
Speaker 3: Not really.
I don't pay a lot of attention to it.
Speaker 1: Republican insider Chris Christie
has written a comprehensive book meant to
guide Republicans away from conspiracy theories.
And he claims not to know what Tucker Carlson
does now.
He may be lying.
He may be lying because he knows exactly what
Tucker does.
He doesn't want to answer for it.
That may be possible, however.
How can you even claim to be an authoritative,
authoritative voice on what Republicans need
to do to push back against conspiracies and
lies and say, I have no idea what happens
on the Tucker Carlson
Speaker 2: truth deniers, conspiracy theorists
on the cover and you attack CNN in the New
York Times and MSNBC enough.
Speaker 3: But excuse me, I don't attack them
as conspiracy theorists or truth deniers,
I talk about bias.
Speaker 2: It is by far more honest to the
country and conspiracy theories.
Speaker 3: No, but that's the third section
of the book where I talk about the movement
forward.
In the census portion of the book, we talk
about the conspiracy theories and the truth
denying that went on with things like Q and
on Pizzagate, the election situation.
John Birch Society.
And that's what I talk about.
There's two sections of the book, and you're
Speaker 1: kind of missing some of the major
stuff from the right.
Speaker 3: I'm sure accidentally you're conflating
Speaker 2: that I'm not conflating them, but
I don't.
I don't think it's an intellectually honest
case to make against conspiracy theories without
taking on Fox News.
Speaker 3: Well, I guess this and then you
can write that in your book.
Speaker 2: Well, I'm not trying to rescue
the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: I understand he's not claiming
to be the she's.
That's it.
It's such a dumb thing for him to say.
We'll put that in your book.
She's not claiming to be the authoritative
voice about the lies and the conspiracies
that that have been told.
But Chris Christie is
Speaker 3: whoever, whatever you want to write
you.
Speaker 2: I guess my question is writing
about our president.
What's your relationship with Fox News?
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, I didn't say
I wanted to run for president.
You said that.
So let's be clear about
Speaker 2: what a lot of people have said.
Answer is you haven't corrected anyone.
Understand that I know Ben and correct the
record.
Speaker 3: No, what I've said is that I certainly
will think about it, but I won't make any
decision for at least another year.
Speaker 2: Do you think that Fox News in primetime
is good for the country or bad?
Speaker 3: Listen, there are shows that I
like and Fox News shows that I don't like
their shows that I like.
Speaker 2: I don't like the purveyors of conspiracy
theories.
And by the
Speaker 3: way, you're but that's your opinion.
You're welcome to your opinion.
Like everybody else in this country is welcome
to your opinion.
I don't consider people like Sean Hannity
or Laura Ingraham, purveyor.
Speaker 2: I didn't say either of their names.
Speaker 1: So, so did you see what just happened?
Nicolle Wallace never mentioned Hannity and
Laura Ingraham.
Chris Christie brought them up, so you could
say, Well, maybe he's got a guilty mind there,
but Hannity and Ingraham are huge.
Hannity was giving medical advice on his show.
Ingram has been on an anti-vax tirade for
six months, so not only did Nicolle Wallace
not bring them up, Chris Christie is lying
about.
They're not.
They are purveyors.
Speaker 3: You said, you said the evening
news programs at Fox,
Speaker 2: the 8:00 p.m. hour.
Speaker 3: Well, and as I told you, I don't
watch the show, so I don't know what Tucker
does from night to night.
If I watch anything at night in news as opposed
to the time I'm watching sports.
But if you're watching anything in news, I'm
usually watching either short or
Speaker 2: so you may or may not support Donald
Trump in twenty twenty four.
You may or may not run for president, and
a book about liars and conspiracy theories
doesn't have anything to say about Fox News.
Speaker 1: This is an excuse.
This is an.
He's written a book, guys
Speaker 3: know the book talks about you continue
to conflate it, and I don't know how you
Speaker 2: think conspiracy theorists without
talking about Fox.
If we was a Republican, I think they did more
damage to the party than anything.
Speaker 3: I'm sure you do.
But if we want to go through that, I think
there are liars and conspiracy theorists on
MSNBC and CNN also.
So maybe I'll write a book about all that,
but that's not what this book is about.
In that section of the book, I'm talking to
Republicans about the way I believe we need
to deal with media to be most effective for
winning, for conspiracy theories and truth.
Speaker 1: Right?
And he got two percent of the vote,
Speaker 3: Ayers, which nobody else on either
side of the aisle is writing about right now
wider than me.
No one else is writing about it, but you want
Speaker 2: to solve them.
Speaker 1: We've done interviews with probably
five to 10 experts on.
What does that mean?
Nobody else is writing about it.
It's it's just an embarrassing interview.
Speaker 2: Jennifer, I want I want the population
of conspiracy theories without dealing with
Fox.
In fact solving terrorism without dealing
with the terrorists.
Speaker 3: Well, look, that's your opinion.
I disagree with your opinion, and I don't
believe and I think it's irresponsible in
the call to analogize Fox News to terrorists,
Speaker 2: by the way.
Well, you know, you write about being a prosecutor
and
Speaker 1: of course, you know, you can argue
Nicolle Wallace made a mistake there with
the analogy, but it's she's not saying Fox
News are terrorists, although you could argue
that there is stochastic terrorism being carried
out on Fox News.
But you could have used any analogy and and
Chris Christie is able to not deal with the
substance of it by saying, You're saying Fox
News are like, it's like saying this is like
dealing with I don't know what it's like dealing
with with a flat tire and having no way to
pump it up.
I don't know.
There's a million different ways it could
have been set.
Her analogy is a good one.
Speaker 2: I want to understand what your
solution is to the title of the book.
It's about truth deniers and conspiracy.
How do we purge the truth deniers and conspiracy
theorists
Speaker 3: from our party?
And it's by telling the truth to our vote?
Where to
Speaker 2: our vote?
Where do you do that right in my book now?
But where do you go?
Where do you buy it?
Go by?
Where do you take it?
Where do you do speeches?
You do it.
Speaker 3: And we're sure I did it at the
Reagan Library in September.
I did that.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Chris Christie is going to solve the problem
by giving a speech at the Reagan Library without
mentioning what's happening on Fox News.
So nice.
99 percent.
Nice job by Nicolle Wallace and the whole
thing feels very grift.
And she's right that it does seem like a pretext
to set himself up to run for president, which
he.
That's fine.
He has every right to do that.
But if that's the idea, we would imagine he's
incentivized not to go after Fox News because
he'll need Fox if he ultimately wants to run
for president.
So there's Chris Christie.
Let me know if you're going to be reading
his book.
I'm all set as I like to say.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at Packman.
Consider yourselves invited to grab a membership
on my website, join Packman dot com, we are
a viewer and listener supported program.
We do an extra show every day for people who
get a membership, and
you can do so in mere seconds at join Pacman
dot com